à l'extérieur les équipes mettent la
touche finale en janvier une fois les
travaux terminés cette école primaire de
Dijon accueillera de nouveau les élèves
pour éviter de gaspiller l'énergie les
murs sont mieux isolés
mais c'est surtout sur le toit que se
trouve la particularité de cet
établissement entièrement rénové des
dizaines de panneaux solaires
permettront à l'école de répandre à ses
besoins énergétiques un projet pilote en
partie financé par l'Union européenne
qui aidera la ville à remplir des
objectifs climatiques et économiques
effectivement on est sur une logique de
baisse de nos coûts donc baisse de nos
charges nous-mêmes en tant
qu'utilisateur en tant que ville
utilisatrice puisque on a beaucoup de
bâtiments publics dans ce secteur une
manière générale sur la ville de Dijon
en fait c'était difficile c'est pour
vocation de devenir une véritable petite
batterie la quantité d'électricité
générée dépassera la consommation de
l’école les surplus seront donc utilisés
ailleurs dans le quartier il va
permettre d'alimenter jusqu'à 14
bâtiments municipaux dans le quartier la
piscine la bibliothèque etc
les
11000 secteurs vont donc profiter
indirectement des panneaux solaires de
l'établissement scolaire une manière de
leur faire comprendre concrètement les
bienfaits d'un tel projet c'est vrai
qu'avec le coût des augmentations de
l'énergie ce projet il prend toute sa
dimension
au-delà de l'école c'est tout ce
quartier populaire qui est appelé à se
transformer dès l'an prochain et
certains édifices résidentiels
disposeront eux aussi de leurs panneaux
solaires
déjà d'autres travaux sont en cours le
but rénové environ 500 unités dans ces
bâtiments datant des années 1970 qui
sont souvent mal isolés
aujourd'hui vous allez perdre de
l'énergie avec les fenêtres qui sont
plus tout à fait étanches le système de
chauffage qui n'est plus tout à fait
efficace et puis également la
ventilation même du bâtiment qui a 30
ans est obsolète
c'est sans compter l'installation d'un
thermostat intelligent pour gérer le
chauffage un système qui s'adapte
automatiquement aux habitudes des
résidents un ensemble de changements qui
devrait permettre 50% d'économie
d'énergie c'est trop bien et vous avez
jamais froid non ah non franchement non
pas comme avant avec les vieux
radiateurs non non ça rien à voir Annie
Geoffroy vit dans son appartement depuis
une trentaine d'années déjà satisfaite
de la simplicité du thermostat qu'on lui
a installé elle souhaite qu'à terme cela
se traduise par des factures d'énergie
moins salées
moins de chauffage moins de charges à
Dijon habitat enfin beaucoup de choses
quoi entreprendre de tels changements
coûte cher dans le cas de Dijon 9
millions d'euros provenant en grande
partie de financement européen mais la
ville est sûr que ce quartier se trouve
aujourd'hui mieux outillés pour
affronter la crise énergétique qui
secoue le continent clairement
l'autoconsommation collective et une
voie d'avenir pas la seule mais d'une
voix d'avenir en matière d'énergie
c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui est énergie
produite sur un territoire consommé sur
le même territoire et un vrai avantage
pour le territoire ces industries ses
habitants ces activités c'est un vrai
avantage
le projet pilote ne doit prendre fin
qu'en 2025 mais déjà les autorités
d'hygenaises évaluent la possibilité
d'étendre le concept à d'autres secteurs
de la ville c'est sans compter les
villes européennes qui s'intéressent de
près à l'expérience qui menée ici pour
transformer un quartier sur le plan
énergétique et environnemental il sera
fait le bouvier au clair Radio-Canada à
Dijon